i'm just living day to day and make sure
that my kids have got the heat in and
they got something to eat it does get
you down a bit as well knowing that
everything's going up and you're trying
to to cope with with everything
i didn't think i'd be in poverty in
old age
this wolverhampton neighborhood is where
fuel poverty's hitting hardest
here 9 out of 10 people can't afford
their energy bills
including single mummy lane it tells you
when it's gone it's running low because
this light here will turn to red when
you get to about one pound seventy
something it'll say to oh you're running
low
at home she monitors the meter
constantly so if i put in 15 pounds it
would go through you know it lasts about
friday but now we're topping it up every
other day
and it's sometimes you have to put in 10
15 20 pounds
rising costs bring hardship and hard
choices always going upstairs at five
o'clock and like you sit in your bed
under your quilt you tell you on your
ass cut over you're saving electric and
gas
this one pot meal class cooks up ways to
feed families and save energy
herbs like with the electric isn't it
you you won't put it until later on
because you're scared and you're
watching it go down you only just cut
down on everything you use like cooking
and
you use your slow roast more than you do
cooker i mean i don't even use my coffee
with five kids charmaine worries about
future fuel bills
that's mainly because of the kids if it
gets too cold like the babies ended up
with bronchitis quite a few times
it's like in two months he's had it six
times in two months all the sevens
77. they're good with numbers here
and keeping track of the cost of heating
i was paying 171 pounds a month but now
they've put it up to 228.
but that's just to start whether they'll
put that off a bit more i don't know
there's nothing we can do about it
really
i mean if we can't afford it we'll just
have to put extra things on and i feel
the cold i really do feel the cold
82 year old graham feels so cold at home
he spends every day on buses well i'm
out i'm going to keep i'm going to eat
on his own i can be out traveling
on the bus or the train
and that's keeping you warm being on the
train yeah there's no trains are warm
enough
and the buses as well
and sometimes it could be cheaper to pop
to popping up and out of drink
and being out and being at home
people here are facing challenges and
making sacrifices like never before it
is all a struggle and soaring fuel
prices will only make that struggle
harder laura bundock sky news
wolverhampton